on the arrival we're gonna start off
here and of course we'll come to the two
of you and you just go with you win
something into the facts which things
have been you see something happen one
of the other cameras you can switch back
there and say if it's there that means
everyone else is safe - yes and you will
be talking over so with you see so who
switches I think somebody's out there
doing a picture taking or arriving and
you guys who's knock yourself out
nothing's happening we're back to you
do you wanna stop
[Music]
we're
got any space
like where do you always work better for
faces if you guys so if you're right he
the interview is right here that's what
my camera shot right right there we
sandwich em well if you guys do that
then yeah then we're gonna be groups
showing up but the singles and stuff
this this looks great
yep okay can we see it oh really
just working I will ask a question like
this you'll ask the question and thought
about it not family and in come back
again remember if you when you ask that
question and you leave that mic right
there okay right it's really easy to do
yeah people do it all the time
we'll be aware will be aware and if you
look over and notice she's not doing it
but you're a mic already yes sir
oh yeah like a deer you know Tom needing
the combo right or if it's like a Mason
Ramsey I'll forsake my microphone it's
amazing man see everybody the whole
[Music]
bring we have questions major are they
walking together
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
I
[Music]
[Music]
little country a little I like to set a
little country I went to them
yeah we'll introduce ourselves
[Music]
hello we are live welcome to the access
online morning toast collab of the year
I have a lot of a century for collab of
the year this year but I can neither
confirm nor deny that we already won
it's true we're about to win welcome
everyone to be here I am Claudia a
shrine
girl with no job some people say I'm
like the Instagrammer of my generation
others say I'm the comedian of my
generation tickets available at Carlton
job calm this is my gorgeous sister four
chairs for all the access viewers we are
sisters co-hosts friends best friends in
fact for all of our morning toast
viewers who are already here waiting hey
guys oh my god we're also Country Music
fanatics so tonight is the night of our
lives we're so happy to be here with
access on the red carpet gonna talk to
some of the country me Hogtown biggest
stars on country music's biggest night
you know it's country music's visit
biggest night and like mother nature
it's not cooperating
no she's not understanding us don't even
know the conditions out here are
biblical ruff ruff the rain but
obviously like my hair stay perfect
thank God and as Luke combs would say
when it rains it pours and tonight it's
pouring and I can't wait to talk to you
about that because all of this is his
fault
tonight it's pouring it's freezing but
we're about to heat up the red carpet
well I think we also are about to have
our very first guest he's very handsome
his name is Travis and we're very
excited to see him hello Jonah hey
handsome welcome to the morning chunk
Claudia hey y'all have alcohol how are
y'all doing I need to ask you in
something I absolutely would love that
I'm about a negative one right now
what's your pick your poison you got
some tequila
of course yeah yeah do some tequila what
I got you coming right up for our guest
Jackie please no that's not to kill a
jack in the middle one so how you doing
Joe you look handsome how much I am
wearing Tom Ford rich just just that
ASOS in a Lucchesi
ASOS a little high level cheers so this
is the morning toast what are you
talking to I know who are you testing to
I'm toasting to
all of our veterans of people who have
served because they are rockstars and I
toasting the country music Amen will
toast to that
cheers hear hear hip hip would you like
a gumball to go with that
nope okay you're good all right well
have a great time you look like you're a
fun guy you are so welcome we're gonna
need that it was about $100 you could
venmo me if you want me to okay once you
get the password to send it over exactly
I get that sometimes too when I complain
about stuff about having no money people
that know me and it's the greatest at
Claudia - all right what's your bed my
username for everyone watching no
actually they really will send you stuff
are you single
I am I and I'm unlike someone I'm
somewhat ready to mingle I get tired and
go to bed audience for you let me toast
errs they're gonna do it so tell
everyone your Instagram just in case it
is Travis our den and god I had to think
about that yeah it's got the blue check
by it I'm not the weirdo asking you for
money or for a gift cards because
apparently that's a pretty big thing
it's a huge industry well it was some
nice chatting with you thank you for
coming had a great time go party yeah
it's a long line keep going now you
could do it by nice to meet you I wasn't
expecting our first guest just like to
come and tell me we had so much to do we
had to open our champagne to open our
champagne we needed to talk about
ourselves because we can't do that
enough and there's so much that happened
in the world today that we need to
discuss but before we do that Jax who
are you wearing
oh I am wearing dolce gabbana ever heard
of them okay someone's cashing in that
picture on Monday who are you Aaron oh
just my friend Ralph Ralph Lauren ever
say Ralph Lauren Ralph Lauren I say
Ralph Lauren I say it if it's as if it's
one word rough Lauren no but Ralph
Lorenz sounds like one word and also for
those who don't know my arm has seen the
light of day for the first time in maybe
three or four years and it's just wild
he like she she she she doesn't know
what to do she's so nervous and
set it to be here but I treat all my
limbs so well your arm is the third
guest the third host of the show tonight
it's literally like the final guest if
your arm could speak what would she say
she would say how grateful she has to be
here how excited honored blessed and
humbled she feels I think and the
toasters know how big of a deal it is to
have army here to not be hammer in the
building but the access stands might not
know you guys is a huge shield stepping
out for the first time recently lost 30
pounds and I just can't stop talking
about it because it's the biggest deal
ever sorry and sorry and I just wasn't
really like in love with my arms it's
like turning into a therapy session I
wasn't really started drinking yet and
now I thought a good way to like roll
back into life with both arms would be
to start with one yes and Here I am
starting with one and it's it's exciting
and it's just I'm feeling a lot of
feelings tonight your bravery knows no
bounds and not to be misleading or
anything but we do look rather tall and
I just need you to know then in a couple
minutes when we cut to the other feeds
we will be taking our shoes off and into
our hotel slippers and we'll be a lot
shorter so I'm about 5 feet we're also
the shortest people here so yeah that'll
become clearer as taller guests arrive
but we have the most spirit and that's
what counts
that's all that counts we have the heart
speaking of spirit this is the morning
toast and we love to toast bread
primarily but also beverages
bread in the morning beverages in the
evening you said it there sister I
stammered it you struggled to get there
but here we are sober you ready we have
a bevy of beverages we thought it would
be smart and wise to stick with
champagne because it's gonna be a long
show I do have a sold-out comedy show
after this so I just you know I gotta be
on my a-game and there's nothing that
gets to me quite like champagne and we
are offering beverages to all of our
guests and who wants to drink alone
other than our first guest anyways
before we really begin the stream even
though we already have we're gonna do a
toast and it's just for everyone's
benefit that I don't do this it's from
the morning toast distillery very
prestigious it's a small town in a oh my
arm I got some free time so like it's
looking a little smaller and we're gonna
do shots of champagne just because we
wanted to feel included with everyone
and that was all we had
that's really why
heavy pour thank you so much sister you
could just leave it right there
how's everyone doing tonight for those
just tuning in hello I'm Claudia this is
my beautiful gorgeous redheaded sister
Jackie and we are the hosts of the daily
live morning show the morning toast and
we are here with Access Hollywood access
online just killing it at the CMAs
honestly like that's basically all we're
doing and we're taking the shot because
everyone around us is gonna be drinking
and it would only be fair that we do the
same and our question of the night
considering where the morning toast is
what are you tossing to tonight so
Claudia I ask you what are you tossing
to tonight I'm toasting to brave Susan
because I feel as if I'm being very
brave out here with my arm and just
being brave and you know myself what are
you you're toasting to his confidence
okay I'm toasting to myself okay there
it was roundabout way of saying it okay
what are you tossing to I'm gonna take
it one step further I'm toasting to us
oh here we are with Access Hollywood
taking the chance on some unknown Steve
yes and we're just so happy to be here
cheers to us and to country music to
country music country music's biggest
night we got to be careful because
champagne is bubbly and I do feel I'm
already over P yeah when you go like
this I got one out to go no I wasn't
ready for honey but a before we jump
right in to country music's biggest
night it was also a rather large day for
like the world so much happened today
that I just feel as if it would be
pertinent for us to discuss it would be
a meet into our regular show this
morning which streams Monday through
Fridays 10:30 a.m. on YouTube and it's
available as a podcast as well so for
all you access viewers I we definitely
of a lot in common if you have s all pop
culture entertainment related hilarity
but here's what happened today re lying
to jr. and Lauren Burnham from the
bachelor/bachelorette have announced
that they're pregnant they're getting
married in June and I can't believe it
actually I can't believe it because we
actually broke the story first in our
Facebook group because someone already
told us about it I thought they're
getting married in January I said you
said June
oh my god baby's coming in June baby's
coming in June married in January so she
was going to be pregnant at the wedding
which is taking place and a lovely
resort in Hawaii but I'm sure we won't
be invited to another social event of
the year just I'm so happy for them but
with all of our news stories tonight we
must find a way to relate it back to
country music in order to be talking
about it on country music's biggest
night well look some friends love
here's thing we have challenged
ourselves and our viewers everything
that's happening in the world the world
really is very small and it does revolve
around country music so Lauren Byrne
oh here I have the great connection of
how this story about it's back to
country music okay Lauren Burnham inari
okay are from the same franchise as
Lauren Bushnell the other Lauren Bay who
is making headlines and I just want to
say I don't want to you know say
anything but we were supposed to break
the news on our show because I knew
about it a couple days ago cuz you know
Lauren's close personal friend and she
promised that she would give me the
exclusive and somebody else got it so
I'm gonna have to talk to her about that
when she gets here and the person who
bought it at Center in x-ray so it's
like hey girl for you congratulations
I don't know I'm just saying you burned
our exclusive sorry she didn't know she
didn't know if she had known she soon as
she put his goldfish she wouldn't have
done that to us women supporting what
she's told me the woman who supports
other women she had the other source
okay okay whatever I know first and
that's really all I personally care
about right and I know that you knew it
first yeah you have someone to vouch for
you there's a witness it's annoying that
was like the world doesn't know that I
knew first and they don't even care but
now they know because the whole world is
watching our stream right now that's
true truly the whole world tell us where
you're tuning in from I'm dying to know
I'm sure everyone is just like we really
are like an international fashion
lifestyle brand similar to that of Sonja
Morgan and I know that our viewers are
just tuning in from all around the world
all around the world this is an
international fashion brand I was like
oh me please please do some I'm Jackee
sister of Claudia post of the morning
toast international fashion and
lifestyle personality a personality
rival some hottie is that who is that
how boy hat I don't know we got to talk
to him I love her dress
so I have something I should wear her in
one of my bridesmaids duties and then in
the coming year what a glamorous punchy
look rayon and they've really embraced
the country music of it all yeah I love
a khaki coat that is brave choice you're
not going to see a lot of khaki out here
cuz it's raining bravery seems to be the
seam on the carpet yeah I totally
they're very cute I love her bump it
thank you that's only a hair you'll see
at the CMAs no it's a good use of bump
it it's also a brave move we've got some
more arrivals that looks like a hottie
named chase rice that I think you need
to talk to a hottie with an earring
that's the thing about CNAs it's like
everyone is so hot it's like a problem
because we're a bunch of married women
marry during age women and we're out
here just looking at some man can
actually trying to set up our sister we
do you have a little sister who we're
gonna push on everything everything
eligible bachelor tonight yeah that'll
be exciting
yeah I wonder he interested I wonder who
the winner is gonna be ooh we have a
blue pen suit that I'm so jealous of and
a pink oh wow
they're meant for each other oh my
goodness they're both really cute that's
a brave a hair choice didn't she was
kind of like trying to emulate you yes
because I think she she's ugly a toaster
because I said on the toast I'm clearly
a redhead and I wanted to wear a
pantsuit look what we have here you did
want a redheaded man too but do how
didn't you end on this look please
explain cuz I know you came to Nashville
with three options I did and I ended on
this look because all of my shopping and
efforts were fruitless of course so I
had to go with something I already owned
I love this dress it's a classic leather
light ruler and I recently very Kris
Jenner I recently got the cutest boots
for my birthday
they're like you can't see them on the
stream unfortunately for all of you but
if you check out my Instagram you can
chat Jackie oh problems just head over
there right now give it a follow and
alike so they are like bows with a
little country vibe and I think you're
together it would just be the perfect
hosting look are you comfortable
I'm so comfortable I'm just like loving
being professional black tie you're very
black tie I am is this event technically
black-tie what's the dress code is there
competition
I think it's black tie okay
well regardless we are going to take a
quick break from our happening
livestream we're gonna cut to some feeds
see some arrivals it's gonna be a good
time make sure you are staying tuned tag
your friends it's very important that
they need to know the morning shows and
access online have partnered up for the
most prestigious show on the red carpet
some would say all would say we'll be
back in just a jiffy so we'll see you
then
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we're
[Music]
[Music]
okay ready hello are we back because
Mason Rams because the biggest star of
the night has arrived I mean Ramsey just
hopped out the car and it's like he knew
that Jackie and I were getting ready to
rebury bring back the stream Claudia had
to take his shoes off she's back to her
normals now you're Mason's height and
you know and I did it out of respect for
the talent that will be speaking to we
have so many questions for Mason Ramsey
but most importantly how's your girl and
how's her family it's what everyone's
dying to know and what he's going to be
asked girls family talk about you girl
I'm gonna hey guys Claudia are a girl
within a job Jackie Oh Jackie Oh problem
hosted the morning toast we are back
here on the cma red apartment partnering
up with access online we thought before
we get imitative it's just like every
guest who wants to come on obviously the
most prestigious show we would play a
little game because we're super we're
super fans like I don't even know how to
how to make an analogy as to how big of
a fans we are investigan is to Bravo as
we are to country music very well said
sister and we have lots of opinions on
some of the nominees some of the winners
some of the snobs so I thought it'd be
fun if we did a prediction like if we
were this if we were the Country Music
Association who would we choose so
here's the first and kind of the biggest
deal is Entertainer of the Year okay who
are my choices Jason Aldean Luke Bryan
Kenny Chesney Chris Stapleton or Keith
Urban wow that's really tough because
they're all so similar and there's where
the win nominee where the women and I
don't really have a horse in this race
I'm not gonna lie I don't mean either
but if I did just like have to choose
from my own personal preferences I would
probably go with Chris Stapleton I might
go with Keith Urban yeah he was my
second choice I just loved Chris
Stapleton I love when someone comes in
hot and then doesn't fade like he really
had a remarkable year last year but it's
kept up the momentum no n Chris
Stapleton is doing a great job of like
crossing over into like mainstream you
guys into her like right partnering up
with Justin Timberlake and just putting
that his best country folks our i
kendall jenner went to a Christian
Concern in LA which like never happens
in country music I live across the
center got to relate it back to country
remember when she blurred out the Kacey
Musgraves billboard that brings me to my
past
that brings me to my next category the
female vocalist of the year we've got
Kelsea Ballerini okay friend of the
toast Miranda Lambert Maren Morris Kacey
Musgraves or Carrie Underwood okay this
is really hard because they all deserve
to win because on a personal level I
have to go Casey because golden hour is
the greatest album ever told of all time
of all time and I know what it's so it's
really not even country I would say now
it's a little bit more alternative indie
so I don't know but then Maren Morris
was part of the big metal song of the
year so she's she's out here doing the
most for country music that would be
wild if she won female vocalist of the
year without even having released an
album right and then Carrie Underwood
had a very tumultuous year Sunday night
Wednesday night 3 oh no no don't stop
your beat stop clapping got a real good
feeling Wednesday night about to happen
that song deserves it came out with her
cry pretty album this year
alright pretties an amazing song Love
Wins is an amazing song Kingdom is an
amazing song and if I need her a in our
person tonight which I probably won't
I'm gonna let them know that Kingdom
should be the next thing out there I'm
out here shelling for a record deal so
if I keep singing just know it's because
like I'm thirsty for my own song we're
out here looking for some bigwigs ok so
did you come up with an answer or no Oh
on a personal level Kacey Musgraves if I
word the Country Music Association
taking a step back and looking at it
carry under one or Kelsea Ballerini like
she's everywhere that's sheer - it
really was a great year for her it was
okay male vocalist of I saw her in
concert as Dierks Bentley Mary Lou Combs
Lynn Thomas red Thomas
Chris Stapleton and Keith Urban and I
think it's important to know honestly I
was so busy doing that I didn't pay
attention my god okay dark smelly arcs
Luke Holmes Thomas Rhett Chris Stapleton
and Keith Urban and I think it's worth
noting that Luke Holmes is nominated for
male vocalist of the year and also
nominated for new artist of the air
which is like a big deal if he wins male
vocalist of the year does that mean he
automatically wins no artists like it
should it should here the male actually
could
female vocalist oh right cuz Lauren
Elena is also in there so I'm going Lu
comas because we stand we in this house
we stand Luke comes and we'll he'll be
dropping by with his gorgeous amazing
wonderful girlfriend Nicole who was also
a fan of the choice because the world
revolves around the morning shows and
the fans of the toasts are
affectionately called toasters I hope
this stream makes you one of them but if
they're in the comments looking for
fellow toasters that's why we're not
trying to buy an appliance so did you
get did you answer me you said Luke oh I
said become yeah I think so chair I mean
that album is just so so great and
something I really want to talk to him
about is he really stabbed them and then
he released a deluxe version with three
extra songs that are the greatest songs
ever and it's like why didn't they make
the cut I think they're maybe even
better that songs were on the original
songs that were on the original but
beautiful crazy was one of the deluxe
songs beautiful crazy she can't help but
amaze me the way that she stands in
ain't afraid to take chances and wears
her heart on her sleeve unless she's not
wearing oh my god the mess has started
hey wait wait we have to bend down
oh me too
Hotel slippers courtesy of the Marriott
oh okay let's keep going vocal duo of
the year unfortunately we were snubbed
in this category and it hurts it's
painful but there's always next year and
we understand cos we respect the Country
Music Awards just as like they respect
us and they have the reason for dummies
and maybe I could do a cartwheel maybe
if we were nominated we wouldn't be able
to do this and honestly I would do this
of course I'm proud here living the
dream okay Vocal Duo of the year
brothers Osbourne dan + Shay Florida
Georgia line Maddie and Tay Sugar Land
how can you change this one no honestly
I can't but I can choose to it's the
year of Dan and Jay it's the year
intention because of tequila but it's
also the year of Florida Georgia line
every year has been the year of Florida
Georgia right so that's this year
specifically has been the year of Dan
and che tequila so Florida Georgia line
I just want to thank them for the work
that they've done in the protection of
me Singh Ramsey yeah they are out here
spearheading the movement including
Jackie's one of the leaders as well but
so is Florida Georgia line making sure
it's well protected well managed Mason
Ramsey for those who don't know we are
dedicated to protecting him and making
sure he stays pure in this crazy
mixed-up world that is art we're making
a valiant effort
we're doing a good job you see my screen
here is the nominees for new artist of
the year here is or here are here are
the nominee here are the nominees new
artist of the year we have Lord Elena
we've got Luke Holmes Chris Jansing
unfamiliar Midland love and Brett young
love well that's hard cuz it's obviously
I think a tie between Luke Combs and
Brett young for me in my heart of hearts
it's a tie between Lincoln Lauren Alaina
oh yeah with Luke um Luke combs coming
out on top just by a hair no Lauren
Elena I'm very excited she talked to her
she is just so vocally talented and I
love the creature attractor we have her
career like she started out on American
Idol
and it's not like she's like today's day
and age where like you go on American
Idol you have a million Instagram
followers and then you had a record deal
because of that like it's not faith
harmony vibe like this is there she
worked hard like she's been in the
country worlds for a long time and now
she's nominated for a new artist of the
year like she really put her blood sweat
and tears into her songs her albums so
good if you haven't taken a listen to
the road less traveled album I suggest
that you do and if you have in it goes a
little something like this
if you trust your rebel heart right into
battle don't be afraid you take the road
less traveled where outchea booze and
kick up the gravel don't be afraid this
one by Lester no she's she's so
deserving of recognition she really
isn't you know who else is deserving of
a five minute break us so guys we will
be right back with some of CMAs top-tier
guests thank you so much for tuning in
make sure to just stay tuned tag your
friends share it on your feed we'll be
back in just a minute
I love
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah we will get will ask you to school
you like to date
we're at Lau we are back with a very
handsome I might add guests hello this
is Josh car hello how you doing great
how are you please turn to the side for
everyone you look very snazzy
okay and then my stylist Ana Redmond had
her person stitch this gold oh that's a
DIY flare
DIY flare good for you well we were
asking you before the break do you drink
I do yeah so you have to I have to
channel those emotions yeah well and I
don't have to drink to do that but yes
that would be bad what G what's your
drink of choice um normally whiskey but
tonight's tequila
we have whiskey too though I think
tonight it's tequila okay clear and I
already you ready start is that way
those photos be like tomato season
especially like exactly it's made of
season with me good okay we're gonna get
you some tequila
speaking of tequila nominated for song
of the year
oh yes you build it all yes great it was
awesome yes welcome to the morning toast
thank you so collaboration with Access
Hollywood perfect this is our live
stream Cheers
Oh cheers Cheers Hugh what are you
tossing - oh thank you what are you
tossing - you a great night of fantastic
performances that's that's it hear hear
anything at myself same performance are
you most looking forward to
well Keith announced on his Instagram
day today is performing my song so how
excited are you excited about that
that's so exciting
what kind of listener what kind of
audience member you were like a dancer
get up or like a sitter and watcher I am
a sitter and watcher like a chronic
sitter in watch I'm a chronic City yeah
I just analyze everything some of
musician and I used to play like on the
road not used to play I still play but
even if you wrote the song and you know
every lyric you don't now the words no
no no no wow that takes a lot of
willpower I don't think I could do the
same I know I just I don't know I just
have like kind of a stone
I'm watching music so I'm actually I've
been practicing like let me show us your
best enjoying face I know we're gonna
get a lot of questions but are you
single I am not very well we're happy
for her or him whoever they may be but
we're happy for them I guess okay here
we are honestly thank you for stopping
by thanks for enjoying our bevy of
beverages and have a great time tonight
go party we can try to like look like
you're enjoying yourself yeah
fine meet you what a good time I can
leave he was like all right I love when
people are Arno and spoiler alert
Claudia did take her shoes off but we
still look the same height it's slipper
season but still boot season yeah I'm
gonna get you guys a glimpse of these
puppies if I have to get a do a
handstand if you were like an audience
member and they put the camera on you
because I feel like maybe two three
years ago Taylor Swift was the only
person who used to actively get up dance
and enjoy award shows and then just like
everyone made fun of her and then
everyone started doing it yeah so you
what is your what's your go-to vibe but
when if you're if you were an audience
member I don't know watch okay well I'm
a I'm a big dancer but I can dance from
my seat I can dance standing up I don't
think I would stand up like I think
that's a little bit first unless
everyone I'm the Great Sea dancer so let
me give you some a please please you
want you want to sing me in a
demonstration okay hear it the first
question people ask me is how your girl
and how's your family and wanna win out
on all the things I used to oh yes if
I'm gonna be famous for some then I'm
gonna be famous for loving you if I'm
gonna be known
world I hope it's because of you girl so
here's the thing I don't know if I've
mentioned this but I actually have it
this is the longest you've ever gone
without mentioning it mentioning what
they give an amazing who's gonna sing
because we're sisters as we're
connecting reader because we see each
chef done yeah we did
shut the who knows my friends Real
Housewives Thank You Jackie by the way
sorry for those just tuning in welcome
I'm Claudia are a girl with no job this
is my gorgeous stunning amazing sister
Wow every time you introduce me it just
gets better I add another attitude I'm
Jackie O Jackie a pleasure it's so hard
for me to get that out well we are here
we are hosted the morning toast we are
collaborating with Access Hollywood
access online to bring you the most
premium show on the carpet we are alive
if you have any questions we are out
here we have the facebook stream pulled
up the YouTube stream pulled up tell
your friends share with your sister your
brother your mother your friends and tag
your family we're country music's
biggest fans on country music's biggest
night there's so much talent coming by
like I'm feeling I'm feeling threatened
I'm not gonna lie because I don't know
if I mentioned this I have an amazing
voice
and I just never got two men China okay
you up but I'm surrounded by people who
actually have like amazing voices and
are recognized worldwide for having said
amazing voices and I'm not gonna lie I
feel very small is that hard for you to
maybe put your heels back on no totally
I feel small literally but also like
physically is that hard for you to be
surrounded by such talent you know it is
cuz I'm really not one to be like
jealous but I definitely feel threatened
okay because it's a these people are
known for their singing voices and I'm
just like known for my Instagram I'm not
one to be jealous but I'm definitely
jealous you know what to feel
competitive but I am you know who I
understand and that's difficult how
could you not there's so much glamour
talent in the room like it's it's an
exciting feeling it's really an exciting
feeling especially like when we first
started it was freezing and I believe
that the temperature is still freezing
but there's so much excitement and so
many people in our shop that like I'm
warm I'm sweating this shot is very desi
oh it's bare yet we're putting the toast
in the morning just cuz it's a warm as
hell well luckily we can only smell one
armpit oh that's true because I'm
showing an arm tonight
army humor meter arrived on the red
carpet army huh
no one knew that she was coming right no
he was like a big surprise because she's
one of the presenters this year and the
world didn't know and that's always
what's the most exciting yeah you never
know what's gonna happen at the CMA
Awards music's biggest night hosted by
country music's biggest fans
that is a great tagline and we didn't
even come up with before we thought of
it on the spot
just just so johnny-on-the-spot so
natural okay so are you having a hard
time cuz like I am just like things so
excited but also trying to talk to you
you know yes and I'm also like trying to
look at you and give you the eye contact
and respect that you deserve but I'm
also looking behind you to like see
who's coming down the pipeline and also
it's just really exciting cuz we have a
lot of people watching right now from
all over the world half of who probably
like watch our show and know SNR
familiar with the pace at which we speak
but there definitely some people who are
tuning in because they like Access
Hollywood on Facebook and are a fan of
their their content and they're just
like oh my god these girls have to stop
talking so fast and we do so let's just
take like a minute we got to slow it
down slow it is we're struggling to do
it for you because we love you who's a
person like you're most excited to see
that you might even like it nervous I'm
like shaken your voice Mason Ramsay of
course and I don't know if she's walking
the carpet but Kelly Clarkson has always
been my dream guest for our show and if
that happened tonight I really don't
think I'm like mentally or physically
prepared I don't think you're prepared
either because we haven't even spoken
about it like it's a possibility I know
because I don't want to get like all
hyped up I don't know if she's welcome
to part I don't know if she's here great
why do I think she's here I don't know
cuz she lives here right and she's on a
song with Dan and check like she clearly
respects the hell out of the Country
Music Association
damn it J is one of the album's this
year that like I consume told heartedly
from start to finish like many times we
listen to it in full bright like as we
were getting ready and it's so good it's
so good at such easy listening what's it
nominated for album of the year
no not even Rob shucking hopefully they
win for duo of the year to make up for
that of course I mean it's great
Aaron it's like regardless of if they
win song of the year for tequila like
staticy Allah was the song of the year
and when I taste tequila baby I still
see yeah cutting up the bar and a
sorority shirt a the same one you were
when we were sky-high
people are like looking around cuz they
think that were like Dan and Shaykh is
we sound so good okay you're dan because
you actually you're shet you're Shay
because you sing and I'm Dan because I
don't okay but you play guitar and I
guess so okay how do I would okay
they're just such the greatest talent do
you think people walking by know that
they're on like the biggest show ever I
don't think they're not acting like it
I'll tell you that very exciting very
exciting lots of just lots of things
going around it's like you never know
everyone in country music is important
but you never know who's a bigwig who's
wearing a wig right you know this is my
natural hair it looks great in a wig
thank God when wore wigs the other night
oh my god those things are tight it was
hard a and so much props and respect to
anyone out there wearing away yeah okay
we're gonna take a quick break and then
we're gonna come back with some premium
guests so make sure to stay exactly
where you are get a snap go to the
bathroom too but you got to jail we'll
be back in a couple minutes with the the
biggest night in country music
[Music]
you should go
big night like country music's biggest
night hello
morning toast Access Hollywood listeners
we are back with the season 7 winner of
the voice craig Wayne Boyd hi how are
you I'm doing wonderful yourself are you
so excited I am so excited this is my
first time on the CMA carpet I've gotten
to do a lot of red carpets but this is
my very first for the CMAs and pump to
be here and when you so happy to meet
you when you were on the voice you were
on Blake Shelton's to him yes are you
gonna like a hug him what kind of
embrace do you give your fellow coach oh
I can't talk about that
oh yeah it's very tough with him because
we'll have a lot of fun well speaking of
red cop would you like a beverage maybe
interest you in a bevy oh okay what are
you drink we got whiskey we got to
killer we got champagne I'm a bourbon
guy okay what's that
which one's burnt makers mark its makers
mark oh there you go also we have it on
good authority that you are right the
keto diet I have been on the keto diet
keto where's ourselves we relate to you
and we know that you can drink actually
as much alcohol as you want that's the
wonderful part of keto you can have all
the fat you want you can have all the
protein you want I'm from Texas
of course we're meat eaters you got to
have that doing so bad tell me a little
bit about the hair and what goes into a
CMA red carpet hair prep this time
around as you noticed it's a little bit
shorter
thanks to my beautiful wife so it's it's
it was a little easier this time I just
you know get up in the morning spray a
little bit of dry shampoo and let's go I
Drive you what grant what brand um
that's a good question ask my wife it's
very tough out here just will you've
blonde hair but dry shampoo turns my
hair white and it's a problem but you
don't have the problem since you have
blonde hair exactly I mean that's the
good part right that's why people go
blonde right to use dry shampoo so what
are you tossing to tonight here in the
morning toast
tell everyone what you're toasting to
I'm gonna toast to a good CMA
and you know what having fun tonight
Amen cheers here here here here y'all
y'all thank you so much for being here
you have a great time go party with your
wife
let's do it she sounds like a fun gal
absolutely with her dry shampoo we love
her thank you guys so don't need to meet
you whew whew cheers Cheers
for the whiskey we should never shops
too drab really gay what if you do I go
from none to one to many you can see the
detailing on his jacket but I believe it
was snakes again oh that is definitely a
skin by the way it's like my dream to
win the boys right you like not only do
that the record deal that you're out
here thirsting for you're also on TV
turn of your greatest dreams achieved
and you get to like hang out with Blake
Shelton Adam Kelly if you were on The
Voice and every chair turned for you
well okay who would you and you know
what I'm gonna go like all judges of all
time cuz I know they said you know yeah
so it's Miley it's J HUD it's Alicia
Keys Gwen Adam Blake Holly Clarkson for
the type of vocalist I'm trying to be it
would have to be someone like Jennifer
Hudson or real Kelly Clarkson or Alicia
probably Alicia Keys oh really and she
has the most Kinect so cuz also her
husband like makes a lot of music so I
could definitely like abused those
connections definitely but I feel like
CMA onion I'm sorry
country artists who team up with Blake
are just like primed for success oh
really and much like Craig Raylan Raylan
Danielle told right
cassadee Pope Shelton is out here just
like generating Talent content music and
lives for the country music industry and
if you haven't watched Cassidy Pope's
voice audition singing torn it's I
highly recommended you love that song
and I know that's what you're saying she
was so good she was tearing up the stage
you know when you can tell like
someone's not even trying and they're
tearing it up
that was her nothing's gone I'm torn I'm
all out of faith the night is jam this
is how I feel I'm cold and I am shamed
lying naked oh it gets a little up
speaking of 90 shams where's Lorna Li
and we got to talk about her leave on
the 90s such a bomb I haven't seen her
hop out the car yet no no because we
have a camera on all the arrivals I saw
him Erin and Ryan heard are here they're
in the building country music king and
queen I saw Maddie and Tay looking so so
Janine and I show a lot of men in hats
and because they were in hats I couldn't
see them but because they were wearing
hats
therefore I presume that they are
importantly special we should wear hats
though maybe we respect honestly we're
getting a ton of us but thank you to
everything if we forget to say it later
Thank You Access Hollywood think you see
a maze thank you for country music
artists thank you to everyone then you
know toasters okay so it's been like 30
minutes how are you feeling I'm feeling
really good okay
oh you know me I get like city tried a
little nervous before and I like build
myself up but being here right here
right now is Maddie and Tay would say in
this moment it's I'm feeling good well
we have that that kind of thing last
year it was like the first 30 minutes
are very quiet and you're like wait is
this it and then an hour goes by where
you can't breathe you don't breathe you
know coffee you don't see us for about
an hour and it's wild and I feel like
that moment's upon us because as you can
see I don't know if you guys can tell
right over in this area there is lots of
humanity just making their way around
before they walk in and it's all
happening in the words of scheana Marie
Shay sorry she dropped the shade scheana
Marie once starts he just can't stop
it's all so I really am enjoying this
time of us catching up really Lam dress
analyzing tonight's award show me Joe
but I'm also excited to talk to you what
presenter tonight hopefully she comes
our way yes I don't know if you've heard
of her Olivia culpo Jackie is her number
one fan I am Margaret a number one hand
I'm gonna number two that Margot is our
little sister snitch your sisters host
of the morning toast in case you don't
know what you're watching
taking over Access Hollywood yeah
there's a lot of premium presenters came
Brown I believe will be here I don't he
wasn't nominated and I think he was a
little upset about it because he said
something on his instil salty but he's
little salty as well he should here's a
great song couple couple of couple great
songs but there's a lot of premium
presenters and that's kind of like my
favorite part last year Karlie Kloss was
here
stop to talk to us which was very
upsetting but I know who walked past us
with a nice chest it's alicia witt from
the Hallmark Channel Oh God Jackie get
her
oh my god I'm looking at her can we grab
her red dress yes okay she just said I'm
losing it we need Alicia wait for all
you home my fans out there I'm gonna get
Alicia tacky if you guys don't know this
is the homework Channel's number one fan
sharing the Christmas new season know
during the offseason is good I don't
watch models the heart freshman father
that's true I'm gonna check you buddy
there's handbook Jackie like wants to
get an audition barks cry oh my god I'm
gonna ask her I wish I just grabbed her
yes please
well how did you analyze we're live we
are live at the morning toast
you guys are somebody home beverage sure
little champagne you got about you clods
can afford it because I've obviously
found the right stop along the red
carpet at the CMA Awards
you definitely have we're also big fans
of yours at big fans of hallmark and
just a season and the new ones coming
out a week from Saturday
we're so excited thank you you have a
drink to drink mm like a pro thank you
so you've been delicious many a tall
mark film yes is your favorite I have to
pick the first one I did which is called
a very merry mix-up it's that's a great
one wearing it in the airport yes
that was a really good and I go home to
the wrong family but he had the right
family it's the right family and that
was the first of what ended up being
many Hallmark Christmas movies that I
did but I didn't know it sounds kind of
silly but I didn't know what a big deal
it was it was the first one I'd been
offered
I loved this script I was like of course
I'm gonna do it I love it and then and
then it became this movie that got
played year after year and although I've
made many since then because of that one
that's the one dearest to my heart
because it was the first and it was like
there were little angels around it it
was like a magical experience for all of
us involved in it
we have many a question about the
logistics behind hilarities cuz they
shot are their shot year-round
yes where did you film that particular
movie well ok hey that one was filmed
outside of Toronto okay correct yeah it
was really snowing Ontario was it
snowing we had snow flurries although we
started in I think late March are we
finished in mid-april what many people
don't know is they're filmed in only
three weeks that was my next question
how long does jae-in days Wow so three
weeks including weekends and the one we
just filmed was actually filmed in
Wethersfield Connecticut which is like a
real hallmark small town town so that
the entire town came out to watch us
film only they are all background
players in our movie and the gift store
on the Main Street actually created a
t-shirt that said I live in a homework
homework Christmas movie town oh my
goodness it was so sweet but the whole
town of Wethersfield which is found it
in like 16 something was featured in our
next movie Wow so that separates woman's
life imitates art yeah well it has been
an absolute joy talking to you you're so
beautiful I hope you have a great time
oh you're welcome
Jackie's a big fan she's being shy but
she's a big fat I said I was ready to
redhead love Hallmark letting you in
thanks June I've never heard that before
thank you for just making premium
content with the Hallmark Channel your
divine Christmas on honeysuckle Lane
November 24 it's not the one shot in
Connecticut yes can't wait we will be
there bye oh man she's so queer chest is
headed Giovanni also we have under the
couple from American Idol behind us and
we gotta get them also the American up I
don't yeah and auntie poppy and her
boyfriend right I love her what what's
his name
Caleb right wait welcome come on in yes
it is I'm gonna say that you are not 21
that is s incorrect so we have some
candy and would you like a gumball
little chocolate
maybe some chocolate the gumbo might not
photograph well yeah
okay you are still precious how old are
you 14 what oh my god he shucked you
feel competitive with Mason Ramsey uh no
his way he's way bigger than me son oh I
disagree
they're actually so weak you are
performing tonight tell everyone a
little bit about your performance okay I
don't know how much I'm allowed to say
exactly is it it's the price I think so
yes very cool so you can tell us
anything about your second toe I could
tell some things I just only get in
trouble but uh I'm gonna be playing the
fiddle me find a fiddle break so you
been doing that I've been playing since
I was three and a half Wow deep talent
needed to watch out I don't think Mason
can play the fiddle how do you fit him I
have it but I just passed him and I kind
of fangirl too little bit we are the
same there's space for more than one
young male on the red carpet we don't
need to beat you guys against each other
so who are you who is someone if you see
it's ain't like you're gonna freak and
be like nervous and starstruck hmm I met
Garth Brooks earlier and that was a
little scary but he was really not so
into bad you know all the new ones are
like you know I just really mean like
Luke owns or somebody like that yeah
we're a medicated
yeah hang out here if you want to yeah
they'll be stopping by more matera we'll
be tackling everyone you mentioned well
it was so nice to meet you thank you for
coming and I hope you have a good time
tonight
yes ma'am would you like another gumball
before you go sure sure exactly one for
the road finally Samia
Brody 14 that could you die like like
when I was 14 I was like I have a
problem I don't know anytime somebody my
own anytime anyone says Garth Brooks I
think of a girth Brooks it's time for
Caleb Lee hutchinson Caleb well time to
meet you I'm Claudia
pardon my sweaty palm I meet you a
sweaty so I was a big fan of this season
I think like there's just so much I came
out of it that I die for and mostly the
relationships cuz you were here with
your girlfriend Maddie who was the
winner of the season correct she's not
here with me now
I actually brought my mom really cute
yes I promised my mom when I was like
five or six that if I ever made it to an
award show that I would take her with me
so you're a man of your word
I try to be at least when it comes to my
mom and I think I definitely have to be
so one of my favorite things about you
was that when you were performing and
you were playing your guitar you've had
your strap and it was like so cute and
monogrammed
and I want to know where is the strap
tonight is he with you you know he's not
with me he's back home I didn't I didn't
bring my guitar with me but you know
maybe if I come back and perform someday
okay
ask believe receive when I do it yes
yeah that's the right attitude Caleb and
tell me the importance behind keeping
the lead in your stage name Caleb Lee
Hutchinson you know it's just my mama
gave me my name and then she gave me all
of it so I didn't figure I'd leave any
of it out and and and of course I asked
them like should I just big Caleb
Hutchinson I just thought it flowed real
well and it's fun for me because I get
to spell it out yeah how old are you I'm
19 so we can't offer you a beverage but
we can't offer you a snack
are you interested chocolate there's
chocolate in those ones yeah go for it
don't whine mind that a bunch of people
already put their dirty hands in there
but just enjoy it enjoy absolutely
believe me he must excited to like sit
and listen to perform or see and meet
and greet I really I'm excited to see
her chair to perform for sure
definitely like his new record is
incredible and I'm obsessed with all his
music and like growing up and singing in
restaurants and stuff I've I know every
one of his songs I'm excited to hear
carry and then see her see her hosts are
you gonna be singing along yes yeah I'm
absolutely gonna be singing along and
they'll probably have to escort me I
have to ask you our final question is
like I said my favorite part is just
like that all the contestants got
together and are dating now because we
have Gabby Barrett and Kay dating and
you and Maddie chu is double date you
feel competitive like what is it there's
a competition
if it was we want that's so buddy no I
kid I love both of them dearly and and
you know me and me and Kate or I
consider my brother truly no it's it's
been a good thing but me and Mady were
the original just set the record
straight well have a good time tonight
go thank you for stopping by have a
great night have a great night and you
look so dapper
thank you bye nice to meet you okay what
a cutie they call me ma'am the vibe that
I get is that totally there is a little
bit of competition hi are you Lucas you
seem like a hugger
if I've ever seen one it's loud right
very us about it who makes it where'd
you get it where can everyone go
purchase one have no idea it showed up
on my door and they said hey can you
wear this tonight and I said absolutely
that's just the best kind of gift the
gift that keeps on giving
Wow it is just a plain black label it
sounds like Kingsman you know it's just
like it showed up I was just literally
got off a plane just in time to get here
from Mexico we were down there raising
money for cystic fibrosis and I didn't
have time to try anything on and it fit
and I was like I'll take that one the
jacket fits like Cinderella shoe fits
well tell us a little bit about what
you're gonna be doing tonight just and
how you're feeling oh it's gonna be a
great night come on Brad and Kerri
hosting is 11 that's Neil right come on
my favorite thing is gonna be here in
Garland sing this elusive song nobody's
hurt right it's a song if you guys don't
know know what they're not telling us
what it is and it's an unreleased song
that nobody has heard yeah Trisha
doesn't even know it that's for sure I
know yeah but it's show Q it it's crazy
she knows much romance on the carpet
tonight right romance and bravery today
I was gonna say to you drink yes what do
you drink we have bourbon me a whiskey
beat to kill Oh me a vodka me champagne
ooh I drink it all let's go with the
tequila
it's so hard look yet oh my god really
really well the pop of pink is working
for you yes here for it we're drinking
champagne Portuguese champagne we can
drink if we drink hard alcohol with
everyone wait wait we wouldn't make it
till 7 o'clock which is when we're
supposed to go until we're doing shots
of champagne champagne
what are you this is the morning toast
what are you testing to life sunrise
sunset a little Tevye well thank you so
much for stopping by we hope you have a
good time tonight and go live your life
so nice to meet you bye also you singing
Fiddler on the Roof it's just incredible
I don't think that's it I think that's
the first amazing second of all that
little kid was the Fiddler on the Roof
okay wait first we gotta get him back
here also Marian and Ryan walked past us
and I have to go dart over there and get
Mike but I don't see her in my viewpoint
anymore but we'll get her back so I'm
still so star shucks over a leash it
would it oh my god wait we never got to
that see this is that's what we're
saying it's like nothing happens and
then everything happens I never even got
to have a set in the her channel at all
the Hallmark Channel wow she live area
is a Hallmark star except she's like
sweating tequila she can do it all she
was so tall like I've never in I I never
feel self-conscious of my height but I
feel aware of it and she in particular
made me feel especially aware of the
fact that I was wearing flats yes she
did
oh so she made me feel very aware of the
fact that I'm not on the Hallmark
Channel so um the stall next to us is
live on a show that I'm in the
background of so like just to make wow
that's exciting let's get Miriam are we
on Entertainment Tonight let's I don't
know my arm is there my arm is that
we're gonna get on we're gonna get up
please we're on the most premium show we
don't even ours let's recap that all I
want to talk about the Kaleb Lee
Hutchinson of it because what a
gentleman what a gentleman what great
skin and like Maddie hat must have it
made in the shade
ma'am no she takes care of em that's
right he takes care of her
Wow and just American Idol I can't
believe they brought it back and it's
like energy OCME and can did I tell you
people start sweating because I've
started Emily I'm sweating in certain
areas and then my toes are still like
mr. deeds
like frozen bright blue blue you know
Iike an axe is that does that only
happen to me like when I wear heels my
toes get like some numb and cold that
definitely only happens to you okay it
doesn't help that my socks are wet from
the monsoon outside right you can blame
we can like mother nature because when
it rains it pours so much going on it's
like what's going on behind me let's see
okay you tell me what's going on behind
me and I'll tell you what's going on
behind you is lots of important
publicist just like making plans
probably like how they can score a spot
on our show if I could guess lots of
important publicists publicizing and
what's going on behind me because the
entrances are behind me I don't think is
going on the way Oh actually some people
are coming from this way and some people
are coming from that way it's just it's
just so you're saying it's a two-way
street the CMAs are a two-way street
which we loathe Association and the fans
okay so we are gonna take a quick five
cut to some of the feeds you'll see some
of the arrivals some of the fashions
some of the premium content this is the
morning toast Access Hollywood take over
we will see you in a bit
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
take whatever you put in those ones okay
we are back with the queen of America
actually Miss Universe I'm sorry I'm
sorry since the queen of the world
wait there's so many things we have to
tell you are you wearing your new watch
do you know what time it is can we get
the time babe okay it's practice well we
have so many things to tell you first of
all I don't know if you know this but
you are an integral part of our show
because the last time we saw each other
was we were leaving a port-o-potty oh
yes I was the owner at Coachella and you
recognized Jackie from her Instagram
which was like the greatest moment of
Jackie's life cause like you're the
queen of Instagram and Jackie's like a
queen and ear peasant a mere peasant and
you were like you recognize me and after
we said that that's just what we say to
everyone so first of all thank you guys
you're welcome
second of all you want the stunning
thank you like just so beautiful thank
you so how are you wearing I'm wearing a
dress by aDNA Vic and my underwear which
is an intricate part of this look so
needs to be shout out is command oh no
that is that is underwear if I've ever
seen it that's actually the underwear
that I typically wear because it goes up
to the bellybutton
I know it does yeah this is going up
pretty high what kind of underwear does
Olivia culpo we're just like to sleep oh
my gosh I'm a big nighty person I love
to feel like good when I'm going to bed
and I like my Calvin's - of course I
should check my Calvin's hashtag app I
like my Calvin's hashtag my Calvin's so
we were traveling yesterday and we were
so tired and we said to each other we
were like how does it live via collage
of it because you are never home where
do you even live like what do you call
home I know well you guys I took the
red-eye last night oh my god I landed
this morning at 5:00 in the morning how
does she do it how do you do it
seriously no we went on two trips back
to back and where land we're like we are
Olivia Copa it's over but you are always
at the airport but you also get to fly
private which is nice but sometimes you
have to be with everybody in fly
commercial yeah absolutely because it
sucks usually it does depends where I'm
going like I'm so excited to be here
tonight and then I'm going to home to
Rhode Island for Thanksgiving and I see
my restaurant my family so you can't
it's just like fine little breaks while
you can but I know you have to just take
breaks what do you put on your face on
the plane well sometimes I wear like the
Freddy Krueger
scary math would you scare everyone on
the plane I scare everyone on the plane
and I don't care no you should I just
really don't know shame no shame well
we're in Vegas I was in Vegas Rwanda
revolve award yes I work collaborate
yeah thank you a collaboration of the
year it was so exciting they said it's
the best collaboration that they've ever
done best it was so happy I was I like
literally got emotional when I heard
that and you just have like the most
going on we have model squad yes which
we consume big fan and fan Oh Julie yeah
we talked about and walk into places
like just like with a camera crew behind
he was like embarrassing or like you
were into it like embracing it no was it
was definitely embarrassing if I usually
for like my friends and family who are
not exposed to that regularly they're
like this is weird
yeah they were just confused and are you
presenting tonight yeah yeah I'm
presenting presenting vocal group of the
year
oh we're not Murray are you biased the
surprise for Sanjay
oh no group group yeah lady lady yeah
Lady Antebellum Old Dominion lanco let's
see like you like had a moment where you
like got the wrong envelope and they
made you say something else like how
would you even like what would you do
like would you leave stage would you
just die like vote you do how happen
recover I would leave stage and die a
little bit but that I would have to go
back on stage and say I'm so sorry I
messed up right everyone kill me no but
you're a pageant queen like zero you
just waltz out there and your pageant
walk you got any round and you would be
fine you have to own up to it I think
taking responsibility is key I said and
since we aren't honored enough to be
here with the queen of Instagram we just
have to take a selfie selfie and then
we'll let you on your way honestly
you're the most beautiful girl I've ever
seen have an amazing time go get in your
life Olivia until Arianna we say hi yes
okay it is a dream and you know what I
thought I would have more time to
prepare no I know we did a job I think
we did a great job and could she be more
beautiful and like small no no she
really couldn't her face is so small a
fellow small face a little small face
like I just I needed more time she's
also a big fan of country music like she
might be on our level like she is always
going to country concerts I going on out
of her way to go to country party so I'm
sure like a lot of things come across
her desk and she was like I want to
present at the sand
how many things come across your desk
would you say a lot actually a lot of
[ __ ] their desk is mess I just
showed you something I came across my
desk before we started like that well
she doesn't hurt and that was messy as
hell right I guess yeah there's a lot of
[ __ ] that comes across my desk but
then the CMAs Access Hollywood comes
across my desk right and here we are in
Venetian Ethan Olivia culpo next thing
you know you're talking about Livi a
cuppa next thing you know Olivia Kobo's
still in your stream looking amazing
I was really hoping that she was gonna
say her underwear were Hanes that's
someone's daughter oh so true and they
have a restaurant together have you been
to the restaurant if you like em you
literally like a tourist destination and
if you watch model spot it was like a
really big deal and it was a huge launch
and like they've taken over their small
town in Rhode Island they really haven't
as she should she has an Olivia couple
way but so funny he's got a full
interview with her and we're still
talking about would you say that Olivia
culpo is the most famous person to come
out of Rhode Island I would yeah I don't
even know anyone to come out of the
smallest state much like the biggest
country music fan country music so I'm
pretty sure behind us our Manny and Ted
okay let's hit them actually right here
right now they're so busy they're so
cute and the Sun also I really McMahon I
also thought they were always like
sisters but they're just friends and
that's like even sweeter like they don't
have to love each other but they do yeah
it's like mmm they're so cute and they
match they match - no they're literally
the cutest girls ever best folks in last
year and I was just like their inner
speaking voices are so soft and lovely
and like whispery that I was like oh
damn and then their singing voices are
just like boom yeehaw girls in a country
song girls in a country song you look so
beautiful I have been missing y'all
since our last interview I've been
having separation anxiety it was one to
remember
one for the body one you guys look so
pretty
who are you wearing I am wearing Ruben
singer Dennis Basso oh my god you guys
look so great you guys are seasoned pros
like when you get nominated for a CMA
you're just like just another one or
you're still like I freaked out yeah we
didn't expect this year to get nominated
just because we've had a crazy couple of
years and kind of like had this weird
thing happened where we had to switch
record labels this whole drama thing but
the fact that our peers still admire
what we do is such an honor and we're in
a category with all of our friends which
is even more fun so as some of your
peers we admire what you do and I just
admire that you guys have deodorant oh
so we left it out for them for when they
stopped by Hubble written on the spot
tell me after you guys can drink oh yes
yeah you just have that porcelain like
skin I didn't know if you maybe we're
underage and I didn't want to be out
here promoting underage Nations was my
head a giant zit on my face this morning
and then my girl Lacey she we call him
Henry and he's a total jerk and he shows
up every year you're se friends of the
year old chin oh my god stop you guys
are so gorgeous but maybe offer you a
beverage
I'll take one what do you want tequila
vodka but we have everything you're the
hostess with the mostess I mean I think
you you're the singers with the mostest
oh I was that I can wait you ask me okay
let him turn into the Sabrina show no
not yet okay because like you your
outfit is so coven lilies have and do I
have tonight's look we're just trying to
pace you look like a baby in the show
well do you would you recommend the show
we need to get back we're talking about
writer Ross's new show you want a
burrito yeah yeah I watch oh that's so
fun Sabrina's Glendale yes so they're
like we should all hang out do this more
often maybe it may be off-camera I don't
know about DME on Instagram yes girl but
no joke we talk more juice off-camera
yes also you guys just released a new
song died from broken heart and it's so
beautiful and I just wanted to tell you
like it made me cry the first time I
heard it it was so sweet and pure
q that means Allah makes me hurt I know
we wrote that when we were going through
like a super rough time and so the fact
that everyone's connecting with it just
makes us feel like we're good I know I'm
doing all right what do you guys
toasting to this is the morning toast
what are you testing to a win health
toasting to health and happiness and
happiness with tequila
come on you guys are so sweet I feel
like you guys have the best time at
these types of things like you just
party and drink and dance alright so go
do what you have to do ladies in your
gorgeous gowns a dame won you a free
performance
I just assumed we could let's shape only
someone could harmonize it bye guys have
a good time I know it's yummy Sabrina
let me know oh my god it's just so nice
to be recognized for the hard work that
we do and to be remembered yeah cuz I
remember them and you're talking on how
sweet they were and how we all like
really connected but you never know if
like they're just acting and they
weren't know because they didn't they
didn't have to yeah they didn't OS
anything wait so let's recap what we
just went there because we still never
recaps Olivia Cobo like we've been dying
to talk to her and she just appeared
behind us like that never happened and
again she recognized us she recognizes
there's a hottie in a red jacket behind
us that I want to talk to do you is he
an artist or is he like just working
here I don't know he's hot that's all I
know I said I can see him from the back
let's just briefly talk about what what
just went on in the past 10 minutes like
we said when it rains it pours here on
this am i red carpet there's 5 minutes
and nothing happened and then there's 10
minutes where you just literally can't
breathe truly truly and just taking in
the sights Matt again today both looked
so pretty and they wanted to ask him but
we said this is one of the questions
that people ask like Julianna asks
everyone did you coordinate your outfit
one set of things has and I really want
to test them do you feel pressure to
coordinate your outfit because you're
always being photographed together right
I guess they do I mean they're not like
coordinated but they definitely don't
but do they have the same stylist for
sure for sure it's like us like we're
always thought about together we don't
even think about it sure yes oh my god
get that [ __ ] over here I didn't see
the sign cassadee Pope yes literally so
any matter her ears must have been
burning
no Cassie Pope has like
of my favorite songs I mean first of all
that you add with Chris Young one more
red lag that's no alien alien I'm just
so excited
hi we are live welcome hi oh my god oh I
love this table there's something for
everyone this is a beautiful table full
of all my favorite things
welcome to Cassidy pub we you look so
gorgeous so I just have to ask are you
of age to drink yes okay you know that's
a compliment right what coming on for
you beef two kilo be a vodka be up
whiskey be a bourbon we have champagne
I'll do I'll do whiskey
thank you yeah I'm done brand I'm just
kidding I'm just trying not to blow you
know use some time oh she means no bueno
I love champagne but I'm still like I'm
not done yet
so no the nights just begin I just begun
thank you guys not doing this with oh
you know we both find twists are our
only special people and we really feel
like you're special because I love your
song alien and I love you do it with
Chris Young like I just said there's so
much that I need to talk to you about
okay well do you want me to let's do the
toast first whisper okay what are you
here I don't know okay and you more I'll
do champagne I'll do to me this team
work I love it okay so we just were
talking to another fellow voice alum and
when you see Blake Shelton on the carpet
what do you do
I give him a big hug right like you see
just the greatest he's the greatest and
he's I mean I owe him so much like I'm
here because of his guidance and so he's
he's the best I love seeing him so since
we're on the morning shows you have to
chose to something what or who were you
talking to I'm toasting to gosh this is
a really good question I'm toasting to
the fellow women in the industry who are
making things happen who are getting
through the obstacles were faced with
and not just getting through but
thriving oh the rock hiding right there
to a couple of thriving females oh maybe
we're offering you a gumball to take
that down when I made where that
chocolate I was going to drop that
gumball is huge no they weren't dirty
nobody seemed to clean look so gorgeous
yes we're saving it for special stuff
those stunning whoo-hoo and what are you
wearing and how long did it take you to
get ready so this is our C Kaelyn and
these are cane and love jewels and then
it well it looks good
that is hard hours well spent takes
three people to be exact
thank you so much for being here thanks
for being fun and go have a good time go
enjoy your life thank you
you know I never really know what to say
to like end the interview so I'm always
just like enjoy your life like what does
it mean right have a great life
oh so we have Walker he's coming up who
I just adore I'm gonna send him to work
because Oh handsome you'll find out why
this one goes have to snitch oh yeah I
know I know exactly what you're gonna do
and that is a strong jawline if I've
ever heard we hugging we were talking
about the jacket with Switzerland so we
heard you're all the way from
Switzerland this is your American award
show it is it is do I look excited you
do and honestly thank you for showing up
in like the most American blazer ever is
it well you know I just thought you know
the Swiss flag is red so I was like you
know gotta I gotta represent right are
you freaking Jew they have a war shows
like this in Switzerland if you like no
oh absolutely yeah Swizz ease
well it's called this well I'm gonna
call them and tell them to change the
name I think is way better way fight
know the Swiss Music Awards which kind
of sounds very formal it's actually a
lot of fun
I'm sure the SMAS yeah we do a good
after-party there too so yeah yeah
Nashville well it's hard to top
Nashville in terms of party you know I
came here for first time three years ago
and I've had the best party in Nashville
for sure
so G you live in Switzerland I kinda
live nowhere and write everywhere at the
same time been traveling for the last
eight years Wow when I'm here in town I
stay at my friend's place he plays
hockey Roman Yossi big fan used to he's
Swiss too so you know we're trying to
write Romanian Swiss happen in America
you're on his turf in Bridgestone right
absolutely yeah we played with Shania
Twain we played bridge summer you open
for her I did open yeah yeah open we're
on the world tour so that was probably
my favorite show first of all in a very
special moment to stay on this stage
where I've seen Rome and played so many
times with the press
I miss allocating just like makin makin
waves in Switzerland in America well I
love it you know I've always been
neutral
yeah well absolutely this is a great
quality we have in Switzerland where we
stand here troll no trouble we stay out
of trouble yeah sure well go party go
have a good time keep me offer you a
beverage before you leave
hey I would love to what do we have
everything a match everything or I'd
describe tequila vodka whiskey bourbon
champagne you know what we're a national
do bourbon minute to think about it but
this is the morning toast so what are
you tossing to with that shot of bourbon
what am i toasted - well I'm toasting to
my first interview with you girls yeah
but not the last
Cheers are you you're not having a shot
with every act are you no no probably
once every 10 shots once it returns yeah
three sure
all right well everybody cheers Cheers
you're chars as they say in Nashville by
so great to meet you every night what
did you wave to Cappy
where'd he go from the other side hi
Judy what's your name hi Justin what's
your name I'm Jackie nice to meet you
how you feeling that's a mighty big hat
it is yeah I'm good how are you guys we
are just living it up good do you drink
of course we figured as much the Hat
really tells a story everything
everything vodka tequila whiskey bourbon
champagne so we have to do now other
questions you do your hat under the hat
or you do your hair under the hat or you
just like throw it on after the shower
and how do you get rid of the mark just
put your hat back up rub it out wait did
you shoot something
oh he is just a man who knows what he
wants
that's what we need living in action
porn it himself where he yells oh we
just took line and we're just trying to
pace ourselves we got a long night we're
working here look at the next one what
are you tossing to with that shot of
bourbon Wow well done well done
taking it down thank you so much for
stopping by I hope you have a great time
and go party with your friends nice to
meet you hi and then I'm just going one
guy's over mom what did I say when it
rains it pours dude I said really
and now Walker Hayes is actually next to
us so we will be look we've just been
admiring it's a party going we got a
full spread
well maybe interest you in food candy a
beverage I've all of the above vodka
tequila bourbon champagne whiskey Don
the carpet what do you need in this ah
what kind of candy do you that's
chocolate right to my heart the sugar
guy chokolate go for it put your own
hands
my hand in there yeah I feel like people
on the red carpet hands right I'm
wearing a white dress guys I've washed
my hands like 30 times today and that's
something you have to think about when
finding the right CMA dresses how many
times you have to wash your hands
probably I probably should have taken
that more into consideration especially
getting down here on a rainy night shoe
but your struggle is good we are good we
are just on the clock so we can't drink
with everyone which is sad no that is
that but you you drink do you make more
under the moments and we'll make up for
it later
how many CMAs have you been to now gosh
I fend with you you know my first time
performing on the CMAs were a couple
years ago I was a part of Carrie
Underwood's all-girl band oh I will be
performing on stage tonight and I'm so
excited that it's so exciting do you
know what Lauren Bushnell I do look how
beautiful she looks I have something for
you when you're ready you look stunning
yeah but now together
guys it's Lauren B and Chris Lane wait
oh yeah that's great
so we're really winding the carpet like
how do you if I get it so much so much I
feel a lot and nobody knows who I am
like ever knows who you are like how do
you feel it's so cool cuz you get to see
your friends right on the carpet it's
amazing how easy a big party that is how
we feel but that's how nobody feels
about us well we hope you have a great
time thank you for stopping by and
starting with us so nice to meet you
last year going on and Lauren B looks
literally designing divine and I didn't
ever talk to her again she doesn't give
us the exclusive yeah we need to be
exclusive we're open we're ready
fabulous for everyone's ready for us
come say hi we're live becomes their
lives
we're live but come say hi you are so
cute and pretty
[Applause]
[Music]
tell anyone we must take it don't worry
it's just girls helping girls don't
worry about it just a little deodorant
you look so pretty where do you want
your dress from okay good good good to
show up as a daughter okay so I'm a
little I'm a little mad and let me tell
you why yeah it's ready to say hi to us
yes boys to girls only but boys continue
a question for him well we don't bite oh
here bourbon here we got you got you hi
oh my god we're just so excited Lauren
we haven't like a little a little tip
and you promised me that I we got the
exclusive on YouTube right here on the
carb and here we are and now these
people next to us got the exclusive this
morning on their website and I don't
know who gave it to them it wasn't made
because I kept a secret and they told
everyone I was like I was being seen
great now I'm like that idiot who
doesn't have a secret so how did that
happen you know what I don't know we
just show up in an award show we put up
put it out into the universe and let you
take care of the rest
congratulations on your blossoming
relationship yeah how did you guys meet
because the last time also we spoke
before that everything always hidden
care offer information for information
and you said I was just named you took
video we're friends he's such a great
guy and here you are like in love so how
does that happen
more than that you known each other for
oh wow at least for a couple years and
kind of just kept in touch and then here
recently started hanging out a little
bit more and realized we enjoy each
other I will say this about her not only
is she beautiful but she's got the best
personality I've ever met it's so true
we can attest to it I agree we're so
happy for you guys and honestly like I'm
so happy for you I just love you more
than life can we can we have a drink to
your breakup what do you need to take
Els he wants turn Cole Swindell drink
Joanna what can we get you what can we
get you what are you drinking
okay okay okay like a proper gentleman
tequila tequila literally right now so I
need it are you wearing JW Marriot
slippers pull my mic what did I say
nothing happens on the carpet for 20
minutes and then everything happens I'm
sweating okay we are live of course is
there any news you want to break are you
pregnant are you pregnant what do you
have to say about the other Lauren B
being pregnant were you confused if
people think it was you I got tagged in
a photo that was okay what are you guys
toasting to tonight here on the morning
toast toast since you are our first cma
together first of many Cheers
well thank you guys for stopping by
thanks for ruining our exclusive and we
hope to see you later text me later
think of any news you want to share I
have a show here if you want to come but
I know you're busy like being a first
lady of country yeah yeah I'll check
soon thank you finally like I just I
feel like I couldn't be myself until I
spoke to them and you know and yes we
had we once had a beautiful Barker I'm
gonna clean up hang on okay we're just
gonna have a quick interlude but you
know what they zoomed in on us our
cameramen are in tune with what's
necessary because they're not focusing
on our dirty bark hard I mean really
appreciate it I just I still can't
believe that Mason hasn't made his way
I'm sorry you're like you're Lauren B is
my Mason Ramsey you know well I hope you
get the feeling that you so desperately
deserve when I get done by the way I
just would like to take a moment to
point out how much lipstick is on both
of our mics it's not our Father there's
no other women in country you guys the
energy the energy is bursting I'm seeing
so many familiar faces I see Cappy who
is
Lu combs his manager I see Nicole
looking we're running where there behind
you
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna be obnoxious
ready because they were all so where did
Cole Swindell go
oh she sees us she saw each other she
can't she wants a shot there's so much
going on I just wish that you could like
to see because you came because it's
electric it's electric du nu nu nu nu
let me you could zoom back out I fixed I
the housekeeper came okay okay Wow Wow
that's all I do our Bethany just just
Wow if you're just tuning in Access
Hollywood go back for bunch of guys
we're making news he has to be in
crystalline just sets out together yeah
he's been we you can rewind so make sure
to do that if you're just tuning in we
haven't had a moment to catch our breath
Claudia are a girl with no job here with
my sister Jackie Oh Jackie oh problem we
are host of the morning toast and we are
doing an amazing collaboration with
access online to bring you the most
premium show here on the red carpet at
the CMA Awards and honestly we've been
deliver as we say that in front of all
of our competition yeah this is they
know they know and like I said I just
wanted to highlight the lipstick on our
on our mics because we worked so hard
maybe they did and that's just a
testament to how hard we work there's so
many handsome fellas here too like if
you're a single woman get to see ma what
are you not doing here
I am it's hard but I guess you know guys
it's very hard my dear is the CMAs I'm
like StubHub I think that you can it
should be for the fans
okay music we're gonna try to Cole
Swindell next and when he says toast I
just want to talk to be have to be like
because we're raising our glasses
it was saving our ass sober see like
that song was written for this exact
moment what do you think he drinks
bourbon away blue combs never mind
incoming it's miss handsome yeah of
course yeah can you breathe oh my god I
love you guys matching in black velvet I
love
how are you good to see ok the view ok
you know what I love you guys so much
I'm willing to have my arm on this side
I've been trying to hide my arm but I'm
so excited to see you guys
the last time we spoke to you which was
one year ago I'm sorry no we saw him at
the concert a month ago oh no sorry we
start with a Content month ago they said
listen bless e amazed we were right here
and when I mean supporters was like in
its moment and it was I was just like
I'm never gonna see this guy again but
here you are new artist of the year and
are you the first person to do that Bo I
don't know I don't know you have to be
I'd have to check the stats yeah you
could only win one which one would you
wanted oh man male vocals yeah yeah I'd
like to skip the news it's like I don't
know it's just like such a crazy step
you know to go from obviously having
them both at the same time so is an
oxymoron in itself so I'm excited
decided to be here so you were on tour
with like 7 million people we were there
it was fantastic don't get me wrong but
you are going on tour by yourself now
which like thank God because it was like
there wasn't enough blue color for me
and get here the whole album I have
something I need to talk to you about
just like you're from a business
perspective
cuz you really start album and it was
everything everything then you release
the deluxe version yes 3 of probably the
best songs on the album and I want to
know why they were like an afterthought
well a couple of them hadn't been
written up when I recorded the album and
then one of them was an older song
actually she got the best of me I wrote
in college and so we we were making the
new album we were like well let's not
put this song that I've already released
out and then it kind of had time to I
don't know it just kind of had time to
sit I guess so so it's business I work
here now it's beautiful crazy about
Nicole
it is actually I wrote it I wrote it
about her and actually played it for her
before you're dating Chuck could you
were trying to court her I was like a
bottle of wine in yeah and he's like oh
check out this new song and I'm like
sitting on the bed and he starts playing
it and I'm just like I drink wine and
coffee every day this is interesting
that her friend was there and I knew it
would really impress her friend even if
she didn't like it that much so then she
would have to at least pretend to like
him so that worked that strategy worked
here we are two years later you know
yeah and also there was a football game
and I'm not gonna lie I don't know what
which teams it was the Univ that going
with your manager Kathy we love and if
your team was a cowboy had to achieve
your beer Oh God so thank God that
didn't happen because that's worse than
any other bet like that's my worst night
Kathy had to shave history what is the
loot commis know that quickly
luke combs diet is when we had cookout
last night in diet it's really whatever
is on post mates that I wanted did you
hear that post Malone spends $40,000 you
heard that I'm gonna Snopes that I don't
know if I believe how much you spend I
would I would I would I would challenge
post to a post mates receipt battle yeah
I'm definitely up to like 20 G's um I'm
Tom I'm a top-ten customer
we're top 5 no doubt my banner up there
with the top 5 to because I've always
ordering for other people because I'm
such like a good hostess and entertainer
you know I think you're performing
tonight yes what are you singing could
you get the best mate she broke my heart
what's my favorite song you mine Oh Lord
and you um probably this one's for you
yeah that's why I named the album after
it oh it was just uh you know it was
cool it was an interesting moment in
time for me when I wrote that helped me
deal with a lot of stuff that I was
going through so I'm special place in my
heart for that song what is your
favorite song and album that song and
probably my favorite factoid about you I
will ever let you go because everyone's
yelling at us but I'll give you a shot
we will give you a new your
complimentary shot my favorite fact
about you we out there then when you go
drinking okay and you do want to be a
tequila yeah babe every single person
okay it's not special
like okay that's everyone's done before
I let you go my favorite fact about you
is that you actually got your start on
vine yes and as a fellow you know
influencer so you mean a little bit
further than me the new thing it's going
to be - are you gonna be on there I'm
already on there you are
breaking breaking news that is just good
manager told you to do that
Cappy that's Cappy all right Cheers wait
so this is the morning toast what do you
guys testing - a couple Samhain arms and
know a couple CMA wins dream big
do you take it you guys have a great
time tonight thank you for stopping by
thank you for respecting the morning
toast I love you so much
there's four people you ended up with
all the ways people see you in February
are you gonna be there - well I have a
show it's sold out it's a nice but I'm
gonna be gone after what are you doing
great cuz I have a party dress that's
right that's truly creative ready to go
we have Cole Swindell
oh my gosh I'm so I was just in your
show in Huntsville yes I don't know if
you saw me backstage I was being such at
the response sir like it was nobody's
business
somebody let me get a backstage pass I
was in Huntsville - I did a sold-out
comedy show tickets available at girl -
Chalmers and it was so great and I just
loved the relief there's there's so many
things about it that I loved do you
prefer to play in like an Alabama verse
like maybe like a New Jersey honest I
mean there's Jersey there's so you were
on tour Dustin Lynch Lauren Elena
spoiler alert she comes out and sings
the middle and it's so good sorry I know
that's like a big spoiler but it's so
great and I just like thank you for
being in tune with what the people want
you know that's that's honestly my
favorite part of the show you know
getting to bring Dustin Lynch back out
and Loren and kind of we get do a little
tribute to nineties country music then
we you know throw a little mix up in
there with
middle which mayor and did an amazing
job of getting the hair Lauren singing
is so cool - she's such a talented boat
for me she's one of my favorite artists
out there boy says having to sing after
her every night is tough she's she's
amazing and deserves all the credit
well you have been waiting very
patiently here for your drink so know
what whatever you want what is your
drink of choice well if I was I have a
bit of a performance I came worth it
there's tequila to that yeah you ain't
worth the risk like a whole thing
planned so if you dislike a will drink
and you watch okay because we do have a
chose path yes I mean how can people
follow you on Instagram oh yes at Cole
Swindell Twitter Instagram look me up
and I wish I had one of those now we're
raising our glass to those saving our
ass overseas am I dreaming
just relax cheers oh if I didn't have to
sing as soon as I get done I'm coming to
find y'all yes and don't drink it all
though don't worry I'm gonna need some
we can't make any promises for some of
the thirst monsters around here exactly
the same because you get a lot of guests
come what one in the show is your is
your performance wait a long time that's
why I even know where I'm gonna come
find yours tonight thanks for being so
cool I love you amazing thank you so
much of course okay you're a natural Wow
so much action over here oh wow oh and I
need to get a lawyer because I have a
million questions for Gabby Barrett and
Margo I hope you're watching this ones
goes out to you oh my gosh is so good we
blast it in the car like it's just if I
were to write a song which I'm telling
you it's gonna happen it's the song that
I would want to write but you took it so
thanks thank you so much I'm gonna take
that as a coffee welcome to the morning
- welcome to the morning toast how old
are you guys I'm 18 so you can have a
bevy you can I'm so sorry maybe but
right now no liability liability okay so
this is your first CMA is coming off of
American Idol like what is it like to
just like go from being a regular
- just not first of all you have great
energy let me just tell you we're tricky
but it's amazing it's real you know
coming off a vital I don't see one of
the biggest platforms that you can
possibly put yourself on so we were
fortunate to make it far in the
competition coming off of it we got on
another tour we're on tour with Chris
Lane
we have singles coming out I have one
coming out in January and almost don't
worry about it
did you guys see your fellow competitor
or Caleb Lee before or did you see him
we haven't seen you do so we're trying
to figure out a way to medium I asked
Caleb's question I would like to see if
you guys have the same response do you
guys feel any way like a little
competitive for the cutest couple
yes like that's a lot he's lying yes
being Caitlyn we absolutely would I mean
thank you so much before we let you go
can we ask you a favor can you sing a
little ditty for us called snitch on the
tour sister is your your biggest fan
like truly and you don't remember this
but at CMA fest we attacked you and
asked you to record a video from their
dating u-verse notation we're so nice
and you didn't even know that like we
were the hosts of the most prestigious
morning show so can you just record a
little time ago like this snitch on the
toast stitch on the toasts snitch on the
toast hey hey hey thank you guys so let
me complete thank you have a great night
go have fun it was so nice to meet you
guys bye
of course I love you bye man I love her
song so much I couldn't remember how do
you guys remember us wait worse we're so
excited
that's boy listen I gotta say Taryn
who's hiding out behind a sputter our
management team she's over there she's a
hardcore toaster I need you to know who
isn't always bringing in it with the
looks last year was a little bit more
rustic this year a little bit more
refined I'm seeing some accents of
velvet tell me about the inspiration
behind these looks
I just went into Chino and they tailored
this I got to pick the fabric and I feel
like a rock star
you look like a rock star thank you so I
cut your music so when you guys you're a
big group I feel like music group these
days like none of them play instruments
like three people you guys are a group
and there's a lot of you and you travel
in a pack always you always take the
same flights we kind of have to be in
the same place at the same time no one
takes an earlier flight no early flights
at all that's me for sure you know do
you guys feel competitive with
pentatonix I guess it's the low voice
it's like I just want you should be on
one of those meditation apps that likes
sings people to sleep I'm gonna do I
reached out to you they have not let's
do it they don't know it's cuz they
don't know but manifest destiny ask
believe receive and now we said it'll
come true right you guys have the best
time ever and you know we never
impatiently okay I mean of course you
guys are my favorite thing to come see
but this just makes it
anyone else for tequila I'll shoot
tequila actually I'm sure I'll have a
game I'd like a man who knows what he
wants you guys are fun tequila that's
perfect
okay so this is the morning to us what
are you guys gonna toast to we're gonna
toast to the CMAs into the morning toast
[Music]
here here hip-hip-hooray are you gonna
walk away with that like that's your
purse or you ran I was you know I would
like to it costs a lot of money Senate
or it's Couture yes you guys have a
great time go party great deal in your
life have a great night oh yes come to
New York
come from York we'll hit up your
publicist for free tickets yeah Claudia
Oscar oh Sh our wine that girls no job
guys I check no problems hi good morning
what as I said what if I say what did I
say when every when it rains it pours so
much going on like I just can't I
finally take a breath honestly Kayla a
Nona taught Cade and Gabi from the
American Idol like admitting that
there's definitely some competitiveness
they're hilarious
you're hilarious and she's so pretty and
that song is so good it's so good it's
so good
her singing speech on toast that song is
so good okay by the way a lot has been
going on if you're if you're new here
here's what's going on I'm Claudia are a
girl but their job this is my gorgeous
stunning amazing beautiful sister she
just keeps getting better
I'm Jackie RA at Tokyo premiere the
hosts of the very popular morning show
the morning show us we go live on
Facebook and YouTube every weekday and
we are partnering up with the most
prestigious media brand out there access
online to take over the CMA red carpet
we are the biggest country music fans as
you can tell like we're not breathing
and get to breathe it's the Maureen - I
love toast in the morning morning toast
I'm Bobby bones and I know you guys know
who I am
yes we do the toasters know you and love
you oh that's right we're not where our
finales Monday
Beaupre Sundance with a star can we vote
for you what we're in the final we did
bone candy here welcoming offer you buck
a beverage are your dancing so you can
well is that gum
my hands are clean huh yes Monday night
Dancing with the Stars vote for us and
nobody else because there there's the
last thing i'ma say before we walk off
everybody else hates puppies except to
us we're the only people that like
puppies on the show so thank you very
much how physically tired are you just
one question
oh I'm good yeah go for it all right
thank you good night you can have us on
your show if you want I won't be upset
we went Mia by country music's biggest
fan Bobby bones his handsome I'm not
gonna lie I knew his name but I didn't
have a space and I just expected him to
look like the lead singer of Rascal
Flatts you know any mean like that's
just the vibe I was going for himself oh
my god get over here right now the Queen
and you are on tour with Harry Styles
who also Falls man Instagram you who are
just everything in the entire world we
have been let me imagine your music
trailer different Park doesn't matter
like you are everything Golden Hour is
the greatest album of our generation I'm
gonna say I'm gonna say you said it it
really is but but we have to talk about
the kendall Jenner of it all because
homegirl blurs you out of her Instagram
hat did you do you bow around Instagram
did you see her you found out yeah I
know I know I saw it I saw myself like I
thought I was like oh but honestly no
shade you know you never know how those
things like she's right and she tweeted
she's a big fan no she's like oh and ran
into her like one of the Harry shows and
whatever but did you speak oh wait you
ran into Harry show were they together
gossiped I'm not inspiration what was
that like like where the girls so loud
I've been to a Harry Styles concert and
like I was deaf I've been out you're on
your own tour and we got tickets we're
having to New York
second show at Beacon Theatre cuz the
first month of sold-out yes I'm very
excited being excited because I haven't
been there yet we're so excited for solo
Kacey Musgraves and I have to listen to
like all the screaming fans of Harry
Styles yeah we were also feeling happy
and sad at the same time right now what
is your favorite song to perform I think
I think it's it feels real good like it
feels like I can find my supplies in
that's what we need right now because
we're we're out of control and we're out
of control
what can we offer you are you a tequila
gal I figured as much
kindred spirits and you know what having
taken a shot with anyone but I'm going
force okay here oh wait okay wow this is
so exciting you look so beautiful by the
way we're rich here you go
I saw you walk by and I was like oh
great I'm never gonna talk to Kasey
Musgraves and now here I am
don't joins out yourself drinking with
Kacey Musgraves Cheers what are you
testing to tonight I I don't know just
like still being alive I guess okay yeah
shutting the album of the year album of
the year oh now I remember I didn't take
it you are just so everything I love you
more than life itself
thank you I just got another my birthday
let's not you're rich what is it
Alessandra rich she's rare like a little
they're very tasty my sweets I'm not
gonna lie oh they are though I'm like
about to go google that right now you're
like your aesthetic is like I feel like
you're so in control of what you wear
and what your set looks like and what
everyone around you airs and you always
have been like from the little blue
outfits and like the cactus vibe to now
just like sparkly AF with long rosy
azulene vials shut up now we see you
girl thank you I'm so so seen right now
oh no I love Rosie and everything she
makes and it's so fun to wear I just
like to have fun with my clothes Erica
and you're not married
I got me Mitch you know your wedding was
like Pinterest to the highest level well
things I'm just like so afraid that's
the last time I'm gonna get to talk to
you that I need to ask you everything
I've ever thought okay John I don't want
to because I know you want to take the
opportunity to talk about dime-store
cowgirl and have that song teacher life
I know you'd be remiss if you did not
thank you for this is why she's a good
sister where's this he reminded me even
better time story cowgirl is it's not
even a sad song
but it makes me cry every time you say
that because my dad and I don't know why
and the song is about an insult it's
supposed to be like it's supposed to be
like super like happy and I'm just like
I am a dime-store cowgirl and I just I
am and I think that's a compliment now
it's like you've changed it into a
compliment well thanks also I just
realized I'm not even holding this I'm
so lazy no I'm just I want to do
everything I can for you to stay here as
long as possible do you have any pizza
oh no but I'll get you time I'll get you
some okay I know you have to go because
you're like so important but thank you
for coming to our little show thank you
so much have fun tonight
bye oh my god I saw her walk by when we
were talking - I didn't like it and I
just like couldn't I was like oh that's
so sad like we're not gonna get to talk
to her
Brett Young's behind us and like I'm his
new way and he's got a ticket to LA and
he's not gonna get on his [ __ ]
Chuckie she said she knew who I was and
she wanted to come over here did you
hear her say that no she said I wanted
to talk to you you're so funny on
Instagram video I was busy I my face is
so red this is what happened last I told
you when it rains it pours actually I
didn't even think she was gonna like do
the red carpet she's so elusive she's so
tiny like I just she's so perfect
another small face there's so many small
faces and big names right name we're in
the background of the picture I got I
got a lot to talk to bright young about
mainly she got married but also just
like how he just decided to become a
singer and became the biggest singer in
the world you know Damian right like his
story is just so
easy that's what I want to become a
singer like just decide when I'm 23 Sam
hunt should I play football or become
the number one singer whose song is
nominee for song of the year two wars in
Iraq twice we're very confused okay
McCreary it goes well last year you
would have been one of maybe two
American Idol former contestants that we
spoke to you are now the fifth how does
that feel yeah I'll take number five
yeah that was a good season for idols
I'll take it yeah and do you still
competitive with Lauren Elena I was
never competitive show she's like a
sister to me
and she's up for new artists and I'm
rooting for so are we oh yeah tell me
about this sparkly ensemble somebody
told me it was sequin year so I just
went with it it's lovely thank you thank
you thank you I would I would never pick
this out for myself but luckily the
stylist for all that that is very true
maybe offer you a beverage to drink
Scotty McCreery yes welcome you offer
you a bourbon whiskey together champagne
that's the cotta solace you have to sing
the song if you were gonna be the first
we're gonna make damn it but just did
one with Kacey Musgraves
and if I do another one I'll die okay
it's okay she's cool but I'm not gonna
lie I'm a Casey Stan and I had to do it
someone that like you haven't met yet
but if you do like you will get so
starstruck and just like cry oh my
goodness not yet but I would get
starstruck and cry I've met him but
Rhett young still makes me cry me too
what a handsome man what a handsome man
very well said Scotty McCreery
so you're here in the mone toast what
are you gonna toast to tonight I'm gonna
chose
I'm gonna toast to my wife first you
make carpet as a married man very well
cheers to her Cheers
enjoy evening bye Scotty
Wow it's like I keep trying to catch my
breath and I can't because the talent is
just there dying to talk to us they
heard they'd heard about us where is
Mason Ramsey okay I feel like he took
his seat I feel like Mason Ramsey like
literally every publication needs to
talk to him but he's here so maybe I
don't know I'm not thinking about Poe
you know what I don't care because Kacey
Musgraves knew who I was and it's always
the thing you don't expect to happen
that happens and he just right I didn't
even think like what would you ask her
because like because we even think she
was on our list but by the way I checked
her off Sybilla I can't turn an
Instagram story today very strategically
and it worked it didn't work why did you
just push me because it worked it worked
it worked it worked
what's up how are you feeling my back
hurts oh my god in there she is there
she ray sing us with her presence like
she's literally the most gorgeous girl
in the entire world like I just and it's
like imagine being so pretty and
talented I don't know I'm just I'm just
pretty
I'm just talented together we're
unstoppable we've never got to like
recap that's the hardest thing home-free
they're so cute they're so cute and I
wish we had them sing for us like they
did last year but it's too loud here it
is very loud and you know what we did in
his Walker haze as well and Bret young
did pass by us but hopefully he will
circle back no it's like once people
walk by us you think that they're done
for good but they're not no you never
know who's just gonna circle back and I
just think an important thing thing for
everyone to note is that Cole Swindell
waited literally ten minutes so he could
take a drink with us and then he didn't
even take one because he's performing
because thank you that command with
willpower and like a professional man
it's like us like barely drinking you
know we could easily do so much more
than we know but like if I if I get
really excited again and want to take
one just like slap me or something
because wait weird yeah I have a
performance today oh [ __ ] yeah oh shoot
Cole Swindell looks like reserving
himself because he's performing I'm
performing a one-one gluing shut up and
remember that I wouldn't have I wouldn't
have led you astray like this good to
our Wrangler I know we have a good two
hour break between the end of the show
has been going at my new show no I'm
just gonna need like I don't know a
grilled cheese a grilled cheese oh my
god and like chicken fingers okay we'll
make it happen
it'll make it hazard and after this Wow
I forgot that you have a show where I
buy tickets if they're curious girls no
job Comi
I forgot about the energy I spent as a
carpet on a show
I know whose people who are watching our
lives being made like you're Kacey
Musgraves moment she recognizes you is
my living a couple more if she
recognized me again
she I guess she did Cody Johnston's
behind us
hello honey I was just looking at all
this I'm trying to figure out how I
haven't been over here yet what can we
get you vodka of course to order vodka
that's awesome I'm kind of an
independent guy anyway she's gonna pour
it up you're such an independent thinker
we're so excited to have you on our show
this is the morning toast we are live on
Access Hollywood and we're just so
excited to be here country music's
biggest dance on country music's biggest
this is my first red carpet Wow how's it
going so far it's going great
you know I've uh I've been looking
forward to kind of doing something like
this for a long time because it has
thank you
I have spent ten years on the road as an
independent artist so we have a brand
new independent album that we recorded
that Warner Nashville has cornered
partnered behind and be coming out 2019
so I'm excited to be invited to the
party a little Warner Nashville muscle
you know I have a question for you
regarding the Hat because you're wearing
it tonight is your hair done under there
it's just completely under it's just
great it's funny you mentioned the Hat
this is kind of a design that we've put
together my friends at resist all cowboy
hats and we have not only the album
coming out in 2019 in January but we
have the Cody Johnson resist all hat
collection where can we get one for you
can go to resist all.com that's done
tall is tol January what are gonna toast
you we're here at the Morning Joe is you
got to make a toast here's the country
music may it live on rock'n'roll no not
rock and roll Jeff no country music is
rock and roll it country music's the new
rock and roll rock starts here - no we
just say stuff don't worry don't worry
about us hey you talk about a rock store
my wife is with me tonight
she is smoking I'm telling show us oh
she is we saw you on the carpet coming
up and down so per day where's your
dress Rob it's the showroom here in
Nashville
you guys are so cute how long have you
been married what is your anniversary
ritual what do you do a lot of times
I've been on the road so actually just
spend time together don't make it about
the gimmicks just actually get to spend
time that's one of the things people
have asked me who are you looking
forward to seeing here her this is a
great time to be together and not have
to be on the road doing the rigmarole
single country stars kill me kill me
okay you guys have a great time so you
enjoy your okay we offer you a beverage
she drove Everage okay fine understand
yeah mo yeah this you know what I'm a
hoarder and I keep clothes forever
I got this 15 years ago I had to change
the zip of the back because it
definitely is tighter than it was 15
years ago but it's actually from Topshop
boutique you know when they have those
racks where there's those lost things
that you can't buy ever again yeah so I
got this thinking one day I'll be able
to wear it and here we are
well if you're wearing it it's a
timeless classic thank you very much is
it how many CMAs have you been - I've
been to a few I've been here with John
and TJ and that's been a thrill to watch
them over the years have such an
incredible time but really the red
carpet and all this is it's quite new to
me still it's quite a novelty us - yes
really maybe offer you a beverage to
take the edge oh hell yeah I mean what's
the candy since you whatever treat
yourself
kiss my arse wheel this let's just take
this with us into the carpet amazing you
look so pretty I hope you have a good
time tonight thank you for stopping by
when you finish it that's cool we're on
our way okay and I really need to
refresh my lipgloss so I'm just gonna do
that on camera oh yeah me too because we
haven't gone to take a Britney my
lipstick this is not sponsored but this
is a great lip gloss oh you can give me
a little Michael Perry that you stole
him snaps my wrist it's tinted lose it
and move it around who's coming who's
coming down the pipe oh just Dustin
Lynch walking past me two years in a row
you know at least he's consistent you
know you know we don't need him ooh that
smells good what what's that coke re
coconut oil it's good to go Carrie call
me I'm not your bro tea for you how are
you feeling what I'm feeling I feel like
so many of my like goals have been
checked off for the evening obviously
the one that is still hovering is Mason
I'm not gonna like let Mason be I'm not
gonna let Mason be the enemy of the good
you know but it's just an amazing night
the room is bursting one of the room is
on fire fire fire no but let you do your
interview over there yeah come back over
here though yeah and bring Carly Parsons
yeah we were squares so Carly Pierce of
it all so four new toasters and four
fans back says Hollywood there's a
wonderful country artist named Carly
Pierce we love her we really like
advocate for her music she worked so
hard and she's such a talented
songwriter talented but we have to say
parse it's a family inside joke that we
there's not enough time to explain to
you but just understand Balto's who's in
the comments Maddox thank you so anyways
her name is Carly Paris but on the toe
she's Carly parts and I really hope now
she stops by because otherwise this was
all for naught otherwise this story was
just a big waste of air time to uh
anyone anyone who will listen because
I've been talking to Armie Hammer
speaking of army how are we doing
tonight we by the way some people might
not know because we made that joke a
long time ago in the stream hello
welcome
oh we the gas meter guy sweet I guess hi
sure breathe in it's Jimmy season you
got anyone who will listen
it's actually my Instagram bio let me
clean up before Jimmy gets here Jimmy's
here laser tattoo shot glasses that we
made everyone like share saliva on and
now it's good to know that no one in the
country music world has herpes or we
think so hi Jimmy
Wow we've heard so much about your doing
how are you that is an outfit if I've
ever seen thank you toasting happen
we're toast what can we get for you
honey whiskey yep maker's mark X the
morning toast I do i do my maker's all
the time that's my semi go-to drink
every day every morning we're happy
because every morning I'm morning shows
are you like Ke$ha do you wake up and
brush your teeth with a bottle of Jack
make a toast here in the morning totally
toasting to I totally word on the street
is that your song is about to go number
one that's just what people are so we
can neither confirm nor deny those
rumors but we heard that it was
definitely true on Monday it is but I'm
toasting my son's a little sick right
now he's for some toasted that my son
gets better me too to that sensei I've
been today well you look so dapper I
feel like you need to do all the press
because like more people need to see
this out agreed so with that we will let
you go just to show more people this
outfit and spread the love thank you
thank you thanks for having me thank you
[Music]
honestly like celebrities are so nice
cuz they're always like nice to see you
and I'm like I know you don't know who I
am it's fine but just like say nice to
meet you like Kate Bosworth did that's
me and I'm like girl I know you don't
know who I am it's fine I don't know yes
no she does she does I just trust me
like I know a lot of people know who I
am I know for sure Kate Bosworth has no
idea who I am you just you never know
you might be a big fan of the memes
I know you can see my shoes I got to
stay over here how are you doing so
funny
oh here's chase rice okay here's trace
rice okay everyone gird your loins it's
chase hello chase right y'all doing
great jump into all the things I need to
talk to you about the last time you were
here I said to you you need to date
someone from The Bachelor lo and behold
everyone heard me and everyone from The
Bachelor started following you on
instagram so you're welcome me who
should I date from The Bachelor well I
would have suggested Lauren Bushnell
cause she's my favorite but Chris Lane
just scooped her up so I wouldn't maybe
suggest like a like a Becca chili
perhaps perhaps do you follow her do you
know her work I know
making matches how are you doing this is
how many CNAs for you now oh now you're
just like not even fazed by all the
glitz and the glam no especially not
tonight cuz it's like I'm actually gonna
dive into what y'all got bury the lead
yeah no Jack Daniels but no um we
actually tequila I'm gonna say impress
them when you taste it when I drink
tequila baby say action there are you
rooting for them tonight come on say
guys they're hilarious man have you ever
get another you know you've you've done
interviews with those guys we have I
don't really have any favorites for
anything I mean most these people are
good people like it Michael Ray was up
for an award with anyone must be nice
not that I know of
they may have beef with me but I don't
well this would be a good time to tell
you about some beef we heard okay next
okay we'll give you a whole list but we
have to say it off camera cuz it's so
controversial this is the morning toast
take a shot who are you toasting - what
are you tossing - I'm toasting to the
fact that I don't have anything to do
after this and I get a drink it was hell
yeah that's I'm it in thank you so much
for stopping by with so nice to meet you
bye oh don't worry I got you I got jobs
I'll DM you honey
ya know he put me on the spot cuz like I
hadn't thought about no and it's like
did you see so many relationship
statuses have changed you see Marty from
girls his mom yes you mean Tom Hanks is
why he's kidding yeah honestly she was
like looking over here like she wanted
to come on and she saw the drink since
she wanted to participate yeah honestly
she didn't I felt sorry that like we
were so busy yeah I know it doesn't
happen anymore by the way what time is
it I feel like I'm in a time warp
I told you that really like zoomed by
wow the show starts in 20 minutes which
means come hell or high water this show
is over in 20 minutes right you know
that's so sad for everyone else right I
was thinking I might have seen a little
more Hallmark stardom Oh God
oh no no just to look like just a
look-alike like I look like a look-alike
how are you feeling I really there's no
one actually there's a few people that
we haven't spoken to Michael Dickerson
goodness I know him and I didn't see him
oh and there is this you know she's on
she's on beep with you-know-who Anna
Anna Kemp
oh yeah and chomsky jumps to me see
honestly I love you but it's truly the
greatest show and it's ending and it's
like her putt like manager like saw me
see her
so can you make the look make the look
be like no it's over oh she's gone she's
gone yeah better Chad I love veep there
may be me son Ramsay was so she's small
that we didn't see him run by us no his
hat is so big and so is his heart a
woman who was searching see if I see him
and like scuba mug should we take a
five-minute break while we hunt down
Mason Ramsey okay that's fair the
hunting of Mason Ramsey we will be back
in a couple minutes just right before we
wrap up so stay tuned we will we're
gonna go wrangle some folks
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and what a whirlwind of emotions of
feelings of alcohol we are unfortunately
honestly they close to red carpet in us
like I was just getting started but I
guess everyone has to go to this thing
called the CMA Awards right and so I
feel like I'm ready to go so if any of
the presenters like you know for I don't
know what happened this was so much fun
two years in a row just killing it
honestly not to toot our own horn but we
have to give the biggest thank you to
access online for giving us this
opportunity this prestigious opportunity
we hope we did you proud thank you to
everyone for tuning in thank you to the
toasters for just being the greatest
listeners alive
anyone you want to thank I just want to
thank Access Hollywood up-and-down for
taking a chance on us and being in tune
with what's necessary I wasn't saying
the CMAs for putting on another
incredible programming other than to
watch it in my green room from my soul
photo I want to thank all of the artists
who stopped by and took a chance on some
unknown scene I want to thank Olivia
culpo for being who she is and I knew
just how I need to think Kacey Musgraves
for acknowledging my presence and also
my Instagram I want to thank her too for
doing that for you because I know she
put you in a fabulous mood this has been
an honor this we are Jacqui and Claudia
Austria hosts of the morning toast which
is the Millennial morning Shelby go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on Facebook and on YouTube and
we're recapping all the things we know
Access Hollywood listeners care about
Bravo The Bachelor literally everything
in the world that exists we talked about
it
reality TV pop culture celeb gossip we
have it and you don't have to be a
millennial to watch it's just at the
time that Millennials prefer to watch
but also some non lonely of some baby
boomers thank you I so love our baby
boomers and this wild roller coaster
that was the CMA Awards red carpet 2008
EMA xt m t x8 h we will see you next
year
thank you guys bye have a good night
that's around